as the country recovers from the impact
of the pandemic white house coronavirus
task force member dr anthony fauci
is issuing this warning ahead of colder
months
what i would like to see is keeping the
lid on it keeping the baseline down
until we get a vaccine
and i do believe we'll likely get a
vaccine
by the end of the year the beginning of
2021 and i think that's going to be the
thing that turns it around
i just think we need to hunker down and
get through
this fall in winter because it's not
going to be easy
dr kanta ahmed is a pulmonologist at nyu
langone and she joins us now to react
doctor
welcome back to the show as always those
are some statements that have caused a
little bit of controversy
by dr fauci do you agree that we need to
be hunkering down as we approach the flu
season and the winter months
well as as physicians and as lung
specialists we are always prepared for
the flu season and i would say because
of the pandemic the silver lining is
we've never been more prepared
for flu than we are now we also know
about the southern hemisphere that's
going through the pandemic
they had record low levels of influenza
and other respiratory viruses that
affect children uh because we're wearing
masks
cleaning our hands and keeping distance
this is going to make a huge dent in flu
numbers but everybody watching
should get ready and go and get their
flu shot as i will this week
yeah i think people are concerned about
what he means by hunker down and they
immediately get concerned about
is does this mean more shutdowns does
this mean i'm going to be inside
for the next few months what does it
exactly mean so we'll stay tuned to see
if he specifies what he meant by that
i want to ask you a question though
because we had a few experts on
earlier uh in the health industry that
we're talking about these
uv lights that are coming out they're
called far uvc lights that are safe for
human exposure
they kill viruses and bacteria on
surfaces they have entry ways that you
can walk through
sounds really promising and exciting but
one thing that occurred to me is
are we over sanitizing ourselves we know
that with the immune system the way that
you build an immune system is that you
have to be exposed to things
even in small doses over time to colds
to flus and whatnot
so is there a risk here of over
sanitizing our bodies
so to answer about the far uvc light
that's an incredible technology that's
been well tested and
if it's placed in a room at the
appropriate height it can kill 99.9
of all viruses within 25 minutes and
this should be pervasive
we've used this kind of uv light for a
long time and uvc does no harm
to the body it cannot even penetrate the
dead skin cells on the surface of the
skin
so i'm in favor of that added to
ventilation and all the other factors
um i'm not sure i agree that we should
think about our measures in the pandemic
is over
sanitizing i disagree with that we
actually are learning that there are so
many things we can mitigate an infection
and still have a robust immune system so
no
i don't agree with that jed
okay well that's really good and
insightful information i'm glad to hear
that it's safe
obviously they said the same um and
we're going to see this being put in a
lot of gyms and a lot of
um a lot of apartment buildings and
whatnot so it's good to hear your take
on that we thank you so much for being
here doctor as always
pleasure jed thank you